my first instant instinct was to ants to
say that you cannot separate the artists
from the art because I'm an intentional
list and believe that meaningful marks
and signs are only meaningful if one
assumes that they've been produced or
designed by an intentional being
therefore the separation of the artists
from the artists is from my point of
view impossible but then I had a second
thought
recalling a colleague who was a terrible
person
he was absolutely untrustworthy and
malevolent said and did horrible things
behind your back but when I invited him
into my class to explain a technical
matter that I would not have been able
to explain he bent himself to the task
in a way so pure that you could see
almost see as he began to talk that the
zeal for his subject burnt away all the
malign aspects of his personality and he
was another person and so it occurred to
me that no doubt there were artists like
that and then I recalled the TS Eliot in
tradition and the individual talent had
indeed defined art and artistry as the
extinction of personality so that the
artist rather than bringing with him and
transmuting all of the him or her and
and transmuting all the aspects of her
personality instead concentrates and
focuses in the way that my colleague did
but then this is all of but then but
then I remembered Woody Allen I
I lived part of the year in Manhattan
and as I went around the corner from my
apartment last year there was a Woody
Allen movie being made so Woody Allen is
right there
what am I to do with that and of course
you can't separate Woody Allen from
Woody Allen movies because Woody Allen
movies are all about Woody Allen
so much so that distinguished actors and
actresses like Michael Caine and others
speak in Woody Allen tones when they
appear in his movies so I thought there
must be a distinction between authors
who perform as my colleague did and burn
away all of their moral warts and
artists like Woody Allen who make art
out of them oral warts so therefore it
would be a wrong act of critical
deportment to ignore that and then I
thought there's also the distance
question Caravaggio
murdered somebody the great English poet
Ben Jonson as far as we know murdered
two people it might have been more but
when I see if Caravaggio painting or
read a Ben Jonson poem I'm not thinking
about that
apparently Robert Frost a great American
poet was also according to his
biographers one of the vilest people who
ever lived the training and being crude
to everyone when when I read the road
not taken' I don't think of that so that
led me to another thought maybe it's
distance maybe the museum effect kicks
in and when they're dead or hanging
somewhere or part of the Harvard library
of classics you don't have to worry
about any of this stuff and then my
final thought was that perhaps this
question the question that we've been
asked here to consider is in fact
misstated because it assumes the
distinct and stable identity of both the
artist and the work of art but in the
last 40 years those assumptions have
been exploded by performance artists
like Emma by people who make art out of
garbage and then steward around the
floor by those like Robert Rauschenberg
who makes art by erasing a drawing of de
Kooning's and say and then says that
destruction is in fact the hallmark of
art
you